Despite knowing better, I, too, have found myself focusing on "urgent work distractions"...
...over important life moments.
Most recently, I found myself texting a client...
...while in the middle of my first child's first ultrasound.
Happy client, guilty mom-to-be.
When you add up all of these moments,...
...the sum total is a life shortchanged on meaning, joy, connection and even memory.
As we remake our models of work in the wake of the pandemic,...
...now is our opportunity to create a new culture that respects time,...
...and the way to make this really big change...
...is through small steps that we can take right now.
The first step that we need to take is to reframe rest.
Reflect for a moment about what you think about when you hear the word "rest."
Sounds amazing, right?
But in my mind,...
...I immediately worry about not being productive enough or letting down my colleagues.
When we do have time off,...
...we need to find ways in which we can enjoy the present moment...
...and savor the leisure time that we have available,...
...as opposed to seeing it as an unproductive barrier to our work.
One specific strategy we can take is to treat our upcoming weekend like a vacation.
On Friday afternoon, jot down how you would act and behave as if you were on a holiday.